[Music]
from warner brothers studios in
hollywood it's the conan audiency awards
celebrating excellence in the sitting
and looking arts
here now is your host conan o'brien
thank you
thank you
that's right ladies and gentlemen
thrilled i get to host the conan
audiency awards and uh you know for a
night this important i think i need to
dress the part bruce if you don't mind
[Music]
here is the audience award statue as you
can tell if you look at it very closely
this took
as much as eight minutes to carefully
craft
out of materials you can find pretty
much anywhere in your basement
but uh seriously uh this is a great
award and uh we've got some very
deserving audience members to present it
to tonight our first audiency
is for best impression of a celebrity
and the audience he goes to the person
in seat 5d for his impression of dave
navarro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is dave navarro
hey man
he's also a silent film star
this next audiency award
the next audience he award for best
impression goes to the person in seat
42n for his impression of warren buffett
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is how billionaires spend their
free time right
i'm gonna go to that free conan taping
the next audiency award for best
impression goes to the person in seat 7p
for his impression of milhouse from the
simpsons
[Music]
this next audiency goes to the person
none of these people are ever coming
back
next auditing goes the person in seat
11k it's the award for the audience
member most likely to be a croatian
hitman
[Music]
[Applause]
something
something tells me we got a little close
to the bone on that one
andy you're starting my car tonight
all right
no no not now oh oh
the next audiency goes to the person in
seat 2g it's the award for the audience
member most likely to be selling illegal
fireworks out of his chevy lumina
[Applause]
[Music]
and our next awards for the worst guy
ever the worst guy ever
worst guy ever and it goes the person in
seat 10 b
[Music]
why is that guy the worst guy ever
probably because of this
[Music]
[Applause]
you